okay we're on YouTube what should the
intelligence community have told the
people before the election well you
should answer that you are in it well I
think that it would have been nice of
course to have a little bit of
information earlier ahead of the
election about what the Russians were
doing I'll tell you that a lot of it was
happening wide open a lot of it was
happening on Rt America which is their
propaganda channel in the United States
so it was barely hidden even the hacks
were designed I think to be discovered
right away so it would have been nice to
have known a little bit earlier we knew
in October where the intelligence
organizations told us in October but
some of our leaders knew ahead of time
were suspected and I think we could have
no more the answer is very simple they
should have told them about both
campaigns what under FBI investigation
not just one going on food for life is
inexplicable sorry you're from the CIA
what is taking so long for all of this
Russia information to come out this
dossier that's everyone's talking about
why is it taking so long well I think
because they're trying to find real
evidence yeah I was rumored I would say
that this is this is a very complicated
thing to map out because there's so much
to discover which is bad news for the
president so I expect this to take it
may take a year or more before we really
have an answer from the FBI damn things
that are taking a long time know about
the IRS audit how long is that going to
go on for
oddities it didn't take forever it got
over at a certain point where is the IRS
doing do you have any authority so
encourage any authority to we keep
introducing what I call resolutions of
inquiry that force votes through having
release of tax returns Republicans
always vote no we fail but what about
the IRS themselves what is their
statement about this I mean first of all
was there ever really an audit can we
get that and we don't know it may won't
tell you they won't
the IRS won't say that and not allowed
to according to them well under new IRS
commissioner is going to be appointed by
Donald Trump so I'm sure the president
will say listen I don't want to take
advantage of being president don't put
me in front of everybody else you know
let me we're in the back of the line of
the honesty I'm good with that I mean I
would never say him and we're like
[ __ ] Charlie Brown we're always
losing which is a bang he's being
audited they can at least corroborate
that they can say if he's lying they
could say no you're actually not being
audited there's not like they're giving
away
he's already declared that he's being
audited and whether he's being audited
or not it doesn't mean he can't release
a tax returns let's be clear about that
and the other thing is that he could he
brought me now he's not already being
audited for last year's tax returns or
what about these so as soon as we get
the tax day let's have him released but
that is his excuse order it is but it's
so on a certain no it does not become
ridiculous I mean how or past that point
I mean we're past that point that's
right of the audit thing they also said
people don't care yeah this is what he
said in 2006 rings which is not true
people really care about this
unfortunately that we was able to put
together a preponderance of the
electorate that didn't I think that's
the bigger issue I think that's the
thing that we should be really scared of
America both again a year and a half so
if you care vote and that's why
and that's why cruise missiles are such
a great distraction you think Susan Rice
is a good distraction try blowing some
[ __ ] up
it's wrestling in a country where you
have no pending hotel deals right yes
right there's no hotels in Syria with
Trump NEMA do you find Chelsea the
criticisms of Kelly Ann's posture in the
Oval Office sexist oh when she was
sitting on the couch does that mean now
I find that pretty Civic to her okay
Anthony you going to run for Orrin
Hatch's Senate seat in 2018 in Utah
we'll see I think I'll pursue public
office again but I have I do not know
yet when or what was the upshot from you
running against Donald Trump there they
hold that against you since they didn't
win for him well I think it's it's I
mean it depends on who you asked if some
people are happy about it others
obviously supporter Donald Trump some of
those who support Donald Trump did so
because they thought I couldn't win and
they they bit there but he seems like he
seems like the Donald Trump seems like
the anti Mitt Romney
I mean Mitt Romney is had sex with the
same woman quietly in the dark decade
Africa well I can tell you this was Mitt
Romney ratings very popular in Turkey it
is big and and Donald Trump is nowhere
near that pot right I'm just saying
Romney may run for the US Senate and you
thought and even though he was one of
the Donald Trump strongest critics
during the campaign I don't think
they're gonna hold it against them and
you talk okay Johnny what's the
historical context of fake news and
Trump's abuse of the media oh god no
that's them again you know I got a
better question if you what's the
consequence of privatizing prisons yes
there we go because that's another thing
they did this recently and like it gets
gets lost in this warm of these right I
mean so just really quickly on the first
question there's a connection between
Joe McCarthy and Donald Trump and you
look at their relationships for the
media they're strikingly similar
actually wrote about this a while back
they also share the common thread of Roy
Cohn you know which people have really
what Wycombe was in the kind of type of
figure he was but the thing that Jill
McCarthy figured out the 1950s was that
he could lie and if he lied kind of
exponentially and people could only fact
check arithmetic alee he would get much
more misinformation out than people
could ever correct Hitler says that he
said people believe a big all right the
big lot and right right and this is the
same sort of philosophy the same sort of
kind of new print that they run on in
terms of the other thing about
privatizing prisons it's pretty
straightforward when you give people a
profit motive they're going to pursue a
profit motive yes industry is not
unrelated we have the largest
incarcerated population in Western world
not unrelated to the fact that people
can actually make money on putting
people in prison and they did every
street and they contribute yes Anna do
you think the Republican leadership is
due for a shake-up Paul Ryan is
mentioned look I think what you saw this
week's newness leaving a what by the way
what I wanted to tell you is it's not
newness he's not Latino Portuguese its
newness making that clear but I think
what happened fortunately little Latino
isn't there something right there I
think what happened this week lunes
itself reservation by the Republican
leadership they realized that America is
pissed off at an investigation that has
no credibility and a guy that has become
the water boy for the White House that
didn't know whether his allegiance was
to an investigation or to the President
and they were hearing from it I think
that had pictures of it all I mean what
a walking mask yes right loser
I assure you Americans we're calling
their Congress people including
Republicans are saying you know what if
we can't vote against noonas but will
vote against you tell Paul Ryan that's
what happened this what you really want
a picture you in 1991 I can picture it I
I don't want mine up it's not as bad as
that the guy
chelsey any reflections on don rickles
yes the world lost don rickles what
about you any reflections for you I mean
I love Don Rickles I remember Don
Rickles on The Tonight Show when I was a
kid it was one of the things that would
make the whole family Don Rickles is on
we don't come down we'd all watch it I
mean there was something amazing about
him and because first of all it was not
stale it was all right off the cuff you
never knew what he was going to say he
didn't know what he was going to say and
and he got away with it you know and and
no I think I think he was a great
comedian and was one of my favorites
what should the u.s. posture be toward
North Korea yeah well you know Trump
this week said if China is not going to
take care of it we will that made me
[ __ ] my pants con that's a bad idea
that's a yeah
Syria does have nuclear weapons North
Korea does we can't launch 59 cruise
missile but what if they have a weapon
that could reach because it's us that's
who it would be reaching here the west
coast now I want my congressman to maybe
that's what we shouldn't do we shouldn't
do what Rex Tillerson did which was
issue a three sentence statement we're
not talking we need to engage when you
get other countries engaged and that's
how we saw what we've done but that's
been going on for 25 years and it
doesn't really do anything because that
guy is a bigger nut than our guy and I
mean Trump is not wrong that it is China
is the is the one that laced that can
solve this again that is correct yes so
how do we get that we can do that not by
issuing statements saying we're not
talking them [ __ ] in the speech
how many when I counted that when he
called China [ __ ] and we still
elected him people it's just amazing in
the Chinese President of meeting with
him that was the one thing we hadn't
tried bill that was the one thing we
hadn't tried
can you imagine how all these doing
world leaders must feel well I know her
and angela merkel's like oh oh
patient gonna say to me person is to
filing the White House I mean they
brought everyone to such a new low I
know well thank God only another seven
years thank you
[Applause]